[Música]
frente a las costas de una isla para
quienes sueñan con desconectarse
[Música]
al cabo de 45 minutos de ferry belly
lammer es un pequeño mundo aparte que
atrae cada año a más de 100.000
visitantes
entre ellos Lindsay y luie dos turistas
que llegaron de Tasmania al sur de
Australia
vivimos también en una isla mucho más
grande que esta hay lindos acantilados
del otro lado vamos a recorrerlos será
agradable
el pacto Palé es como la puerta de
entrada a believe es una de las cuatro
pequeñas ciudades de este trozo de
tierra de 85 metros cuadrados que cuenta
con 5000 habitantes al año e igual
número de residencias secundarias
nuestra pareja de turistas australianos
y sus amigos se dirigieron al occidente
de La Isla para pasear en los senderos
costeros estos antiguos senderos
aduaneros trazados para facilitar la
observación les ofrecen una vista
maravillosa Los visitantes en especial
en los famosos picos de pocotón
caminar y admirar estos paisajes aleja
el estrés
preguntábamos Cómo se vería con una
tormenta debe ser espectacular
los acantilados y el color del agua
su transparencia que permite ver las
rocas totalmente
Pero también es la buena cuchara la que
atrae a los turistas susán segundo
puerto de La Isla es el lugar predilecto
de los fanáticos del pescado fresco
Miriam quien vino de vacaciones hace 38
años conoció al pescador Joan françois
han permanecido juntos
ya no queda sino una decena de
pescadores profesionales en la isla a
los que les gusta la venta directa aquí
hay dos rodaballos
y aquí hay bogavante y un centollo
grande
fue una buena pesca qué piensas no
estuvo mal hoy
en verano
son los peores meses son los meses en
los que se pesca menos en especial en
agosto sí agosto siempre es el problema
es cuando hay más demanda Entonces es un
poco estresante es estresante
les gusta mucho saber de dónde viene
Cómo cocinarlo hay que dar un poco las
recetas porque a veces creen que es
complicado hacer pescado
cuando en realidad no lo es puede ser
muy sencillo el rapé por ejemplo no se
hace solo al estilo armoricano puede ser
filete de rape en sartén con un poco de
aceite de oliva es perfecto y si hay
alguien que sabe como sublimar el
pescado es christoff hoy solo hay rape
no hay rodaballo
hace 27 años que este dueño de
restaurante le compra cotidianamente su
pescado a Miriam esta noche será asado
derrape cocinado a su manera haremos
rápido
y una vinagreta de granada
coliflor
cebolla verde
unas cuantas gotas de nuognam
porque adoro Asia esta vez le dará un
buen color que quede bonito 5 minutos en
el sartén 5 minutos en el horno y listo
es uno de los platos más apreciados de
Los visitantes en su restaurante vamos a
cortarlo así lindo
alejándose un poco de la orilla en el
corazón de la zona rural florecida de
Bell Hill podemos descubrir uno de los
tesoros secretos de la isla ningún gesto
brusco no gritar No inquietarse si una
abeja se les ubica encima no les hará
nada Solo viene sobre ustedes para
sentirlos
instalado desde hace 13 años que entran
apicultor les propone a los turistas un
encuentro punzante con la abeja negra
una especie en Vía de extinción en el
continente
en el interior si rasgo ahí bien líquida
debajo
voy a degustar
muy buena están fabricando miel una
escupe el néctar y otra se lo traga a
quien tan le gusta a los turistas
así como muchos otros habitantes de La
Isla ver nuevas caras durante el verano
es una bocanada de oxígeno es también
una forma de ser anónimo de nuevo lo que
es inestable en estar un poco en la
muchedumbre no conocerá todo el mundo es
agradable pues trae entusiasmo la gente
en vacaciones nos hace viajar porque yo
en primavera a verano no puedo irme de
vacaciones pero verlos a ellos de
vacaciones me hace viajar también aquí
una abeja están haciendo
en las colmenas de quien tan zumban
40.000 abejas negras lejos de las
amenazas en el Continente esta especie
encontró en la isla un entorno
conservado y un oasis de paz Esta es tal
vez la clave del secreto de Bely y
[Música]